on est un parti de gouvernement on
aspire à gouverner à nouveau le pays il
faut être responsable on peut pas être
démagogique vous savez si on réformait
pas les retraites on tenait pas le
système donc il y a trois solutions soit
on augmente les cotisations ça veut dire
quoi ça veut dire une baisse des
salaires ça veut dire des coûts de
production plus élevés pour les
entreprises perte de compétitivité soit
de l'autre côté autre solution on baisse
massivement les pensions d'ailleurs le
corps parle d'un taux de remplacement
c'est à dire l'écart entre la retraite
et le dernier salaire qui s'effondrerait
en 2050 moi je récuse ces deux options
je veux pas qu'on baisse les salaires
enfin je veux pas qu'on augmente les
cotisations et donc on baisse les
salaires et je veux pas qu'on baisse les
pensions donc il restait qu'une solution
c'est travailler un peu plus tous les
pays l'ont fait